can the rumbling ever be fully Justified
to answer this question the first thing
we have to acknowledge is that on the
island you have maybe about a million
people who would be saved by the
rumbling while across the sea you have
billions of innocent people who would be
destroyed by the rumbling this would
literally be the equivalent to Hawaii
nuking the rest of the planet to
guarantee their own Survival it just
doesn't make much logical sense of
course for the people of eldia they do
have the right to defend themselves but
do they have the right to defend
themselves at the cost of every other
living thing on the planet for most
reasonable people the answer to that
question is probably no however it would
have been Justified if they had done a
small scale rumbling just like they
originally planned